in wildstar all sorts of shiny baubles
compete for your attention
developer carbine studios apparently
unable to choose a single audio visual
style squeezed multiple ones together
crafting a potpourri that's as eclectic
as the game's narrative themes you hear
references to Star Wars and the Lord of
the Rings films in the soundtrack there
are robots and hoverboards and
references to left4dead
in wildstar the pop-culture references
float freely down a river of science
fiction fantasy and comic book themes
this concoction makes for an overwrought
aesthetic often beautiful and sometimes
gaudy but the world of Nexus is almost
always interesting to look at so even
when you feel the grind while chasing
the game's countless missions you'll
probably still want to push forward if
only to see what interesting sights
you'll encounter next the colorful and
referential aesthetic pulls you in
making you despair when war spoils the
beauty even if you're the kind to skip
past all the dialogue and just get to
the action the audiovisual barrage does
a fantastic job of veiling the clockwork
nature of the ai-controlled characters
that engage in loud battles I was
invested in this war that raged between
the Exile and Dominion factions as a
result not every quest takes you to such
interesting places I spent more time
acting as a wedding planner for talking
bunny rabbits than I care to recount and
carbine seems more concerned with giving
you as many things as possible to click
on than with making all those things
feel meaningful but you can still find
value in the busy work particularly when
pursuing tasks related to your chosen
path your path is separate from your
combat class scientists keep themselves
busy fixing robots adventurers leap to
higher ground looking for artifacts and
hidden nooks as a settler I collected
resources and use them to erect various
machines for giving other players health
boosts and building taxi stands so that
my fellow exiles could travel more
efficiently I liked knowing that these
side activities didn't just benefit me
but the people around me wildstar makes
movement in combat energetic and
enjoyable this isn't the first MMOG to
include a double jump but it's the first
such double
that has felt so free and easy though
the occasional invisible wall can hinder
that joy nonetheless wildstar is focused
on keeping you in motion the combat is
still built around a skill hotbar but
skill cooldowns are quick and most
skills are assigned an area of effect
rather than acting on a single target
skill is typically emanate from your
feet and arcs cones circles and
rectangles affecting the players and
creatures unlucky enough to stand within
range of your fury enemies Telegraph
their strongest attacks with similar
tells and the most powerful of them
require you to roll and leap around to
avoid the red patches that designate
dangerous areas out in the rolling hills
and snow-covered meadows of Nexus this
makes for a fun adventuring whether
you're on your own or tagging along with
other players in the game's dungeons and
adventure scenarios tensions rise
substantially in one dungeon for
instance treacherous spheroids radiates
from the final boss temporarily turning
wildstar into kind of a bullet hell
shooter such battles require you to keep
a close eye on enemy behavior but the
chaos is rarely overpowering as a result
these challenges are welcomed outliers
in a genre rarely singled out for
requiring reflexes cooperative levels
called adventures are the most rewarding
places to prove your mettle given their
creative use of ideas not often
associated with MMO geez the war of the
wilds adventure for instance
appropriates elements of MOBAs
unleashing waves of AI grunts that
complicate your goal of capturing more
flags than your computer-controlled
rivals adventures are fun and more
vitally they're fun to return to again
and again player versus player
battlegrounds are subject to the whims
of human players making them even more
frantic than adventures and dungeons
actually PvP can get a little too
frantic and some battles require all of
your senses
just to make sense of the hodgepodge of
the red and green arcs that criss cross
each other on the grounds these capture
the flag and assault and defend variants
are fortunately exciting even when the
visuals approach anarchy if you'd rather
escape to a more restful place you can
take advantage of player housing your
home is not just a house but an entire
floating island upon which your abode is
one element you can plant gardens set up
healing stations and even erect a
dungeon upon your island in the sky thus
making your home a useful destination
and not just a virtual status symbol
some players have used the items they
purchase and collect to craft jumping
puzzles personally I've approached my
house is more of a dollhouse spending
way too much gold to decorate it
wildstar's attitude is brassy and brazen
it's Christmas worn off on me somewhat
but I'm still planning to stick with it
for a few months to come if only because
it keeps luring me onward with trails of
colorful candy pieces wildstar is not
changing the MMOG paradigm but it makes
a fine case that fun is a legitimate
cornerstone around which to construct a
massive adventure
[Music]
you
[Music]